أنا الأمريكي الفلسطيني الوحيد الذي
يخدم في الكونجرس، سيدي الرئيس،
ووجهة نظري مطلوبة هنا الآن أكثر من
أي وقت مضى. لن أصمت
ولن أسمح لك بتشويه كلامي، فكرة
أن انتقاد حكومة
إسرائيل هو معاداة للسامية للغاية.
سابقة خطيرة وتم استخدامها
لإسكات الأصوات المتنوعة التي تتحدث
عن حقوق الإنسان في جميع أنحاء أمتنا، هل
تدرك ما يشبه الأمر، سيدي الرئيس، بالنسبة
للأشخاص خارج القاعة الذين
يستمعون الآن في عذاب إلى
حكومتهم التي تجردهم من إنسانيتهم
للاستماع إلى رئيس الولايات المتحدة
الدول التي ساعدناها في انتخاب عدد القتلى المتنازع عليها
بينما نشاهد فيديو تلو الآخر
للأطفال والآباء القتلى تحت الأنقاض، السيد الرئيس،
هل تعرف كيف يكون الشعور
بالخوف؟ ارتفاع جرائم الكراهية لمعرفة كيف
تجعلنا كراهية الإسلام ومعاداة السامية
أقل أمانًا، لا أستطيع  أعتقد أنني يجب أن
أقول هذا ولكن الشعب الفلسطيني لا يمكن
التخلص منه،
فنحن
بشر مثل أي شخص آخر،
جدتي سيبي مثل جميع
الفلسطينيين تريد فقط أن تعيش حياتها
بحرية وكرامة إنسانية نستحقها جميعًا